ماذا لو تم اغتيال  رئيس كوريا الشمالية؟
لكن الخروج عن المألوف سيكلف الكثير،،
ومن هي الدول التي تريد اغتيال كيم جونغ؟...
أسئلة تتبادر إلى الذهن عند التفكير بحل
لمستقبل كوريا الشمالية بدون كيم جونغ ونظامه....
وستكون الإجابة عن الأسئلة في دقائق هذا الفيديو
فتابعونا ولا تنسو الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة
وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله..
تسعى بعض الدول لإزاحة كيم جونغ ونظامه عن حكم كوريا الشمالية،
لكن ماذا لو نجحوا حقا باغتيال كيم جونغ؟
لو تم اغتيال الزعيم الكوري الشمالي فهذه هي السيناريوهات المتوقعة..
أولا... حرب شاملة..
فربما يستمر جيش كوريا الشمالية، في الحرب مع أي دولة
تتدخل لقتل زعيمهم،
وقد تصل لحرب نووية كبرى،
ويمكن لكوريا الشمالية أن تستخدم أيضا الصواريخ الكيماوية
باتجاه العديد من الدول،
وقد يصل بعضا منها للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية...
ثانيا... حرب أهلية،،،
يعتقد أن كيم جونغ قد أسس سلطة حكم متداخلة
يمكنها السيطرة على البلاد بدونه،
وهو ما يعني أن إدارة البلاد ربما لا تكون واضحة المعالم،
وقد يقود ذلك إلى صراع بين قادة الجيش والمدنيين.
وقد تتطور الحرب لتصل للجارة كوريا الجنوبية
التي قد تسعى للسيطرة على جارتها الشمالية...
ثالثا... انهيار كوريا الشمالية...
وهو أسوء الاحتمالات وأخطرها،،
وفي هذا الوضع ستسعى كل من كوريا الجنوبية والصين وأمريكا
لاحتلال  كوريا الشمالية،
والدخول في حرب مع بقايا الجيش الكوري
ومع المقاومة التي ستتشكل للدفاع عن وطنها،،،
رابعا... توحيد شبه الجزيرة الكورية...
وهذا السيناريو يلقى رواجا لدى الجارة الجنوبية
وجزء من مواطني كوريا الشمالية،
ففي حال موافقة قادة كوريا الشمالية
سيتم اتباع طريقة اتحاد ألمانيا الشرقية بألمانيا الغربية...
إضافة أن هذا الاتحاد قد يكلف قرابة ال٥ مليارات دولار
لمساواة الشعبين،، فدخل الفرد في الدولة الشمالية
يساوي فقط 5% من دخل نظيره في الجنوبية حاليا،
وهو ما سيجبر الحكومتين على مساواتهما...
قد يفكر كثير من سكان كوريا الشمالية أن اغتيال زعيمهم
سيؤدي بهم إلى جزء من الحرية التي يتمنونها
لكن هذا لا يضمن سلامة بلدهم،،،،
،بينما تتقدم الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية السباق
لاغتيال كيم جونغ الذي يعتبر عدوها الأول في الوقت الحاضر،
فإن ذلك سيعد مخالفة لسياسة أمريكا الذي دامت لأكثر من أربعة عقود،
وعلى أي حال فإنها ليست فكرة جيدة  للوقت الحاضر
، فاغتيال كيم جونغ أون ليس شيئا يمكن أن يحدث بسهولة،
خصوصا وأن كوريا الشمالية تعتبر كتلة سوداء للمخابرات الأمريكية،
يصعب اختراقها والتجسس عليها،
ويستحل معرفة من سيستطيع الوصول لسدة الحكم إن سقط كيم جونغ،
ولا ننسى أيضا أن هناك وريث جاهز لحكم البلاد في حال وفاة كيم جونغ،
وهي شقيقته كيم يو جونغ والتي تعتبر أخطر امرأة في كوريا الشمالية
ولا يخالف شقيقها أي رغبة لها،
بل أن كيم جونغ أون بأفعاله لا يساوي إلا القليل
أمام شقيقته....
وتأتي الجارة كوريا الجنوبية في طليعة الدول التي تريد،
اغتيال كيم جونغ، خوفا من تهديد السلاح النووي ،
وليبتعدوا عن تهديدات كيم جونغ بإعلان الحرب عليهم
فكوريا الجنوبية ستكون مع أي مخطط لاغتيال كيم جونغ
لكن دون إلحاق الضرر بها...
. وأما الصين فستسعى لاحتلال كوريا الشمالية عسكريا،
لو تم اغتيال كيم جونغ، للاستفادة من الأسلحة الكيماوية والنووية،
ولكي لا تسيطر أمريكا على دولة حدودية معها
فهذا يشكل خطرا عليها...
فهل سيكون اغتيال كيم جونغ حلا ناجعا لجيرانه من الدول
وللمواطنين الكوريين أنفسهم؟